apparently Boris Johnson is not at all
popular with the public what would you
say to that
when I say there's only one poll
whichever matters K and that's the poll
that takes place during a general
election and Boris Johnson won as an
80-seat majority at the last General
action less than three years ago there
are polls come and go and and I'm afraid
I don't actually take an awful lot of
notice of them because there's only one
that matters and and as you know we won
an 80-seat majority absolutely
um
yes indeed
um he's going to be finding it hard to
celebrate the Commonwealth Games though
isn't he because of what what has
happened what has the nation lost do you
think as far as Boris Johnson is
concerned when he resigned
so I think he lost somebody who took us
through a pandemic who gave the
conservative party my party an 80 seat
majority something that hasn't happened
since the 40 years he gave us a mandate
he took us through a pandemic which has
had Global repercussions he led us and
and was the first Global leader to help
Ukraine and and helped us lead a um an
effort to support Ukraine through
Putin's barbaric attack he ensured and
guaranteed that we were the first
country in the world to get a
vaccination into somebody's arm as part
of the the war on covid and and also
helped to take us into economic growth
out of the pandemic so I think Boris
Johnson's achieved a huge amount and and
for me they are the signs of a great
leader what they achieve when they're in
office and I think he did that you were
devastated weren't you when it happened
tell us how you felt
um I was very disappointed I thought it
was a huge mistake but what I would say
is that
um in this trust we have somebody who
has both integrity and loyalty and is is
is able to pick up the Baton using those
very important qualities to take the
country forward so I think you know what
happened has happened we have to look to
the Future now and for me personally I'm
looking to Liz truss who I think has
many of those qualities and and will be
able to step into the role as prime
minister from day one hit the ground
running and be able to deal with some of
the very complex problems that we're
facing as a nation as a result of a
global pandemic and because of the war
in Ukraine the effects of which are
still going on today and we will still
feel for the future to come
to what extent do you blame Rishi sunak
for Boris Johnson's demise
so look I don't want to get into the
lyric so as you can see Kay behind me
there are dancers
nearly onto that yeah I'll come on to
that as I said right at the beginning
I'm asking you whether to what extent do
you blame uh Rishi sunat for Boris
Johnson's demise
so it is it is not a secret that
um that we that things that things
happen that shouldn't have happened and
that
um Boris Johnson was removed via a coup
but I don't know if you can hear behind
me but I'm in Birmingham and today is
the first day of the Commonwealth Games
which is going to be the most successful
games
and athletes
I want to know what you think about
Rishi sunak and what uh to what extent
he uh was responsible for the demise of
Boris Johnson and then we will come on
to the uh games in the fullness of time
look Kate I don't want to
um today because it's the opening of The
Commonwealth Games because we have the
lionesses going to Wembley on Sunday
because these few days are going to be
fantastic at sporting events not just
the sport not just the Commonwealth but
for women particularly today is the day
I don't want to engage in the leadership
I want to talk about the really
important things that are happening here
in Birmingham and the West Midlands and
in Wembley on Sunday because I'm the
secretary of state for dcms this is what
my department has been working on we
even have one of our own civil servants
competing from my department in the
Commonwealth Games today for me the next
few days are not about leadership
they're about showcasing what is great
about this country what is great about
the West Midlands and what is the
important things that are happening here
in Birmingham today so the leadership
race isn't important for the next few
days
so the leadership race is going to go on
all through the summer and will conclude
on September 5th at which point we will
have a new leader and a new prime
minister for the next few days please
forgive me but I am going to focus on
what we've been working on in my
department for years before I arrived
you know we delivered these games in
four and a half years it takes seven
normally we delivered them on budget the
government's invested over 600 million
pounds in these games for me that today
is an important day it's the opening of
something we've been working on as a
government honest Department over a
number of years and I mean forgive me I
want to focus on the positives about
what's Happening Here the athletes who
are here can be saying the thousands of
volunteers that we have working here and
the buzz which is in this city today
there's been nothing as big as this in
this country since 2012 in the Olympics
it's a really important day and I think
we should be focusing on the positives
and shall we be spending 778 million
pounds on a vanity project
it's not a vanity project okay come on
this is this is hugely important you're
saying we shouldn't have the
Commonwealth Games I think we are proud
and honored to have picked up the Baton
when it was dropped elsewhere in the
world and to continue to run these
Commonwealth Games in The Amazing way
that we have done everybody here
thousands of people are extremely proud
including the volunteers behind me right
now extremely proud of what we're doing
are you know the Commonwealth it's an
important organization particularly in
light of what's happening globally on
the geopolitical front and in
particularly with Russia and China and
the war in Ukraine it's more important
than ever and these games they symbolize
that they symbolize the coming together
of those nature those Nations so of
course it should be it's not vanity
project it's an important project and
it's one we should continue